from afar the world is blue with an
all-encompassing ocean the source of all
life
without the ocean earth would be as
bleak as barren as Mars or the moon with
every drop of water you drink every
breath you take there connected things
better
like lumisi generates about 70% of the
oxygen in the atmosphere it absorbs much
of a carbon dioxide the ocean tribes
climate and weather regulates stabilizes
temperature shapes Earth's chemistry
water evaporates from the surface of the
sea forms clouds the return water to
land Nancy his rain sleet
the ocean covers nearly three-quarters
of the Earth's surface but that's just
the surface
the average depth is four kilometers the
maximum 11 kilometers seven miles down
97% of Earth's water is ocean
it should be no surprise that 97% of
births living space is ocean space the
greatest abundance and diversity of life
is there with forms that represent
nearly all of the major categories
plants animals and microbes that exist
on earth
life abounds even at the greatest depth
where the pressure is more than a
thousand times greater than at the
surface diving into the sea is like
diving into the history of life on Earth
we're creatures proceed humankind like
hundreds of millions appears
it's a vast liquid realm where
diaphanous creatures time jellies squids
silvery fish creatures that illuminate
the deep-sea darkness with their own
living white
the terrain below holds most of the
world's mountains entire chains of Peaks
that run down the major ocean basins
like giant backbones
most of the planets volcanoes are in the
see many forming the underpinnings of
islands such as Hawaii the Galapagos
Iceland and thousands of others
with new technologies submarines ships
satellites we've discovered more about
the ocean in the past half-century than
during all preceding history yet most of
the ocean about 95% has yet to be seen
by human eyes let alone explored far
into the 20th century people thought
that the sea was infinite in its
capacity to heal whatever we wanted to
take from him
accept whatever we disposed of there
over the years hundreds of millions of
tons of ocean wildlife have been
extracted
and hundreds of millions of tons of
noxious waste have been put into the
scene
industrial fishing has depleted fish and
other ocean wildlife some nearly to
extinction many large and even small
species of creatures have declined by
more than 90% in half a century
trolls and nets scraped the seafloor to
catch shrimp the bottom-dwelling fish
scallops and oysters
they're the equivalent of using
bulldozers to catch songbirds and
squirrels pollutants from agriculture
industrial waste and sewage have seeped
into the ocean accumulating in the rain
organisms even in the icy waters of the
Arctic and the Antarctic more than 300
dead zones out darkened coastal areas
plastic debris has dumped in such
quantities that a huge floating mass of
garbage twice the size of Texas has
formed in the Pacific and plastic clogs
the shores of even remote Pacific
Islands the construction of coastal
cities has brought about the loss of
coral reefs mangrove forests and vast
wetlands and the birds and marine life
that once thrived there
recent changes in the ocean are
compounding the impacts of global
warming and in turn climate change
increasing sea level and acidification
are altering the nature of you
now we know one of the great discoveries
of our time is that there are limits to
what we can take out and what we can put
in without dire consequences to the
nature of the ocean thus to the
underpinnings of what makes life
possible from us
now that we know we can do what it takes
to reverse the troubling trends to treat
the ocean as if our lives depend on it
because they do
you